i want you to resolve this fight i'm
having with my um girlfriend oh yeah
what's going on so what do you drive and
what are your thoughts on let me ask you
okay that's a little too direct okay all
right um
you know what i just that was rude of me
you're gonna lead the witness no i'm
just saying that because joe scarborough
when he does it with his girlfriend mika
he does that a lot what does he do he'll
like stop her from talking
oh that's okay no he'll just interrupt i
don't want to do that because i think
it's now i'm so mindful about it and i
just go joe don't do that you know what
i mean mika has a brain you know so it's
like i don't want to do that you're the
best okay go ahead
go ahead go ahead okay anyway
i'm excited i've already gone to therapy
recently so i'm going to try like on me
or with you guys but yeah what's going
on so um why is there beef
what's going on again
the beef is this the
beef is this okay
that um you know i don't know
you haven't seen my prius but it's
you know it's three doors three
yeah it's broken the fourth one has yeah
has perished i rammed it into sam
tripoli's car once on purpose i can see
that you're right and he had a brand new
guy just rammed it in there because i
was so mad at him and i just use it i
always had shitty cars and so for once i
went you know what i'm sober again i'm
gonna get a nice car right so
i want to get a range rover
evoke there you go my girlfriend that's
the car i drove here my girlfriend just
got that car i swear to god it's out
front do you want to see it
dude my girlfriend has a nicer car than
me i have a 2017 bmw that's hilarious
already
i have a 2017 bmw i got it i got it used
yeah because i like for me i think all
this is gonna go away eventually like it
should be like oh you're not funny you
boo you suck ah you're broke yeah yeah
so i like i bought like a cheat i bought
a used car with like 10 000 miles on it
because i'd like i want a nice car but i
want to like humble myself yeah but you
know
but my girlfriend's in finance she has
very she's a lot of stability at her job
and i'm like i don't am i going to do
haha tonight or am i doing it
yeah so so what you're saying to me is
is that
her car is better than your car it's
nicer yeah nicer she just got it
yesterday over here oh and is is the
range river evoke nice
it's
[Laughter]
which way should i go with it
so i'm joe scarborough simple question
should bobby lee in his career be
driving a range road i think lamborghini
urus that's the lamborghini suv
right here we go how much is it uh 200k
yeah
it's such a good car it's such a good
car yeah i can't i'm not i know at that
level you guys are oh i'm not at that
level oh why why i'm in the podcast
i know you're pulling on this trevor
keep in mind he cannot um have nice
things he will destroy it
how long did you have the prius for uh
decade decade wow so
walk me through the range rover you're
like it's nice
i told him why don't you go to range
rover to get the range rover yeah right
and then he went over there and he was
like oh i like this little
pokemon thing it is a smaller one oh you
want you know lazy yes yeah the bigger
ones look like him
and i don't want to go inside him all
right uh i i want to go inside like
you don't know doc willis but a little
bit no dog yeah a little whirlpool oh
you want a dock i want to talk willis
range rover rather than a chappelle lazy
or yeah you want like the boston terrier
of course
yeah
yeah i feel that so um is is your
girlfriend asian no she white yeah okay
and she's in finance in finance right
per chance does she look like malibu
barbie
no blonde hair
no burnette yeah yeah um so um she has
one and you think it's nice and do you
think it's nicer than yours um
do you think that if i drove around it
would you tease me
no i think it would honestly fit you
i think because you're about to make me
cry no it it's like it feels like a big
car on the inside but from the outside
it's like it's like a little like peanut
like a peanut m m on wheels that's what
i wanted
i read that in your interview a couple
years ago so you always wanted
yeah i always wanted so so you want him
to get the bigger one i just wanted him
if it were up to me i'd want him to get
a corolla
he just doesn't know he's going to
destroy whatever he gets i'm like
corolla good safety rating
um toyota reliable
when you see an asian driving a toyota
what do you really feel my jewish friend
i feel
good
everybody that's somebody who believes
in their own product
you know what's crazy since my mom's
jewish and i told her i was getting a
bmw she's like don't do that it's a
german car
yeah but like
hitler did one thing but the bmw
so um i i honestly i think god spoke
through trevor wallace right and i think
i'm definitely gonna get i'm gonna call
sam now saying we're gonna buy the car
right no but i'll talk hold on how do
you feel about a weekend car versus
weekday car like your spots car corolla
people do that
yeah i mean brandon shop has a
dealership at his house
he does yeah i don't have brendan schaub
bucks what about we just like beef up
the prius a little bit add shin guards
to it that if he got a brand new prius
and actually put a wrap on it my dad has
a brand new prius
oh yeah
yeah you look like you had a good
upbringing
that was pretty straightforward yeah
yeah my mom would like have like weird
rules in the house like i couldn't have
cereal with more than seven grams of
sugar
it's just like white people trying to
make rules they're like you can't have
cereal with sugar
all right raisin